[Music]
hey you guys time once again for another
tomes of terror
and today we're talking about a little
slim
novel that came out uh quite a while ago
by a rather established
horror author today we're going to be
talking about
a little book called mrs god
by peter straub now there's kind of an
interesting story
behind not only kind of the publication
of this book but also how i ended up
reviewing it this week and also kind of
demonstrates
how much of an idiot i will well i'm not
going to say how much of an idiot i am
but how
i've read so many books that i can't
remember which ones that i've read
before
all right so basically what ended up
happening a couple of weeks ago
i was in downtown sanford and i was
perusing through a very large used book
and record store down there
i think it's called maya's and i was
looking for some more books to review on
the show because
even though i have like a huge pile that
i still have to get through you can
never have enough books you know how
that goes
so i saw this one this little hardback
uh by peter straub and i was like oh man
it's like i've never heard of that one
and it was only a couple of bucks so i
thought well i'll pick that one up and i
picked up a bunch of other ones too
which i will review later on when i
started reading this book
i was like this sounds like a little bit
familiar so then i went online and did a
little bit of research into this book
and it turns out
that mrs god was actually
originally sort of a novella short story
but still quite long
in this uh short story collection
called houses without doors
which uh i bought many years ago i can't
even remember like how many years ago i
read this
so it turned out that i had actually
read this book before
but that i hadn't really remembered it
now i'm not sure if the version that's
in houses without doors is exactly the
same like i skimmed through this version
here
uh in the paperback and like it seemed
like the beginning and the end were the
same but i think it's a little bit
shorter so i think that this was
actually kind of expanded out
to novel length i guess even though it's
actually still
quite quite short i think it's only like
156 pages something like that did i get
that right 181 i was a little bit off
but yeah that's still pretty uh short
for our novel so what ended up happening
with this novel
particularly was that it was first
released in 1990
like as a limited edition and i think
it was only like 1200 1300 copies
something like that
and i think like the first 600 that came
out were like super special edition they
had like really nice leather covers and
they were all signed by the author and
everything like that
and then later on it was kind of
released in houses without doors i
believe and then it was released as a
trade hardback which this is right here
even though i had read this before
i didn't really remember that much about
it so it was almost kind of like reading
a new thing
so you know so basically i think when i
started reading this again
uh the only part of this story that i
remembered from the my original reading
of it was
the part where the guy like the main
protagonist who's an american and he
goes to
england for you know a research
fellowship or something which i'll get
into in a bit
and i found it very amusing like all of
the stuff about
him kind of having culture shock i
suppose that like going to england for
the first time and you know stuff about
like the plowman's lunch like him not
knowing what that is and like being
bummed out when they bring it to him
because it's like what is just like a
wedge of bread and cheese what the [ __ ]
is this about
so stuff like that and me being an
american who
in the 90s and 2000s uh went back and
forth to england a great deal of time so
that
so that kind of thing like amused me so
it's not surprising that
that that was like the main thing about
the story that like stuck with me i
guess because
even though i didn't have exactly the
same experiences i could see where the
dude was
coming from like you know being an
american and going there for the first
time and like this
being like a weird like a weird alien
civilization or
just like in little things that stuck
out to you so i think that that was
maybe why i remembered it so the story
of mrs god
is about this guy named william standish
and he's like an academic
and he works at this or he's like um
teaches at this kind of
uh small but you know rather prestigious
college i guess it's not like a big
deal one or anything but it's like you
know i guess sort of well-regarded um
he's basically i guess like his
superiors i'm not
real familiar with how like all like how
academia works so
you know correct me if i'm wrong but
they're basically getting on his case
too it's like look you haven't published
um you know your i don't know if he's
going for a phd or you haven't published
a thesis or something like that but
they're basically like well
you need to publish something like
significant or you're out on your ass or
you have to look for another job or
something like that
so he basically decides that he's going
to
do he wants to do like this huge
research project which he hopes will
turn into a book about a distant
relative of his
um i believe it's his grandmother or his
great-grandmother isabelle standish
who who was a poet like back in the day
and who he
feels is like the lost emily dickinson
and like nobody knows about her
and so he's kind of gonna bring her
genius like into the light i suppose
so what ends up happening is that he
gets word that he is the recipient of a
very very prestigious
and very rare fellowship at this place
called s
wood house which is like this big manor
house
in england that's owned by the seneschal
family and it's basically like
over the years has become like this
massive repository of
very rare you know kind of literary
artifacts from like very famous writers
t.s eliot
ezra pound henry james like all these
people
in the universe of the book actually
stayed at this
house uh for time periods and like left
some of their very valuable papers there
like as a thank you
and implication too like later on in the
story is that
a lot of these writers most famous
works may have been inspired by some
stuff that went on at this manor house
so what is it so william standish who
i have to say is not the world's most
likable dude
but you know bear with me on that he has
a wife named jean
who is pregnant at the time that he gets
the fellowship now originally the
fellowship is only for three weeks
but he the way that he thinks about his
wife and the way that he talks about his
wife
peter straub doesn't go a huge amount i
think a lot of this story it's very like
i said it's very short
but a lot of the stuff that happens in
it is just like implication
so if you're not reading it really
carefully like because i never really
got whether like i got that william
standish was
repulsed by his wife not only because
she was pregnant because he just calls
her like
you know the way he thinks of her as
like just this big giant bulbous
you know like he thinks of her as
disgusting but also
i think that she had had an affair
with like his academic rival at the
college i think is the implication
now i don't know there was a pregnancy
at some point in the past but i
wasn't clear over whether she miscarried
or whether
she got an abortion at his behest or the
other guy's behaving like that
but there's been some kind of there was
some kind of like scandal that he
doesn't really go into a lot of detail
about
um so that was something that was kind
of going on in the background
which was another thing that made him
very excited to get this fellowship
because he could get away from this
wife who had become very repulsive to
him so
he goes over to england to s wood house
by himself i mean his wife is like
fixing to pop man it's only like you
know
a month or something away but he's like
oh i'll be back before the baby is born
it's fine or whatever even though he's
he really in reality doesn't really seem
to get that much of a crap
but you know just to make her feel
better i guess he says that so he goes
over to england and
when he gets over there he's initially
very charmed and like i said he
he thinks of it almost like a weird
alien civilization because he's never
been there and he just
he finds everything very strange but
also like
kind of delightful you know what i mean
but as soon as he gets there
like it starts getting pretty weird like
almost immediately like
he rents a car and then he has a map
because like i said this happened back
in 1990 so no gps or nothing like that
you had to use paper maps
i this part of the book i think was
probably my favorite part like this
beginning part
because it was like regular [ __ ] but
then
it was there was just like all these
creepy little details like he'd be
driving
you know in this kind of through this
village or whatever and he sees like a
face at a window that he's not sure that
he saw
um he stops at a pub to get some food
and he's like
thinking to himself like oh this is so
charming and i can tell people i stopped
at this little place and
i had this and that and it was like he's
he's like always thinking to himself
like how he can tell somebody else
about what he was doing like it was i
don't know it's just like really funny
but so the place that he stops at though
there's like some kind of weird [ __ ]
going on in there too like the
like the pub guy there's nobody else in
the pub except for the publican
and this other girl who was his wife
daughter i don't know but she's like
really heavily pregnant as well which i
guess was kind of like a
throwback to like william's wife and the
publican is like really
a little bit uh rude and he's basically
like oh what are you going to s
woodhouse for it's like somebody got
murdered up there and all this other
stuff
then he basically like something weird
happens with the pregnant girl and like
like they kick william out like hey
we're closed now and like he just
takes the wedge of cheese like from miss
plowman's lunch and he's like outside
what the [ __ ] just happened so there's
all that kind of [ __ ] like building up
to it
now when he gets to this manor house
it's really weird because
he first meets this woman and he is
immediately like
taken with this woman who you you're not
really sure
she doesn't say what her name is she
doesn't say what her
position is like is she the housekeeper
is she like his
handler like who is this person um but
she's very charming
she seems a little flirtatious or at
least that's how he perceives it
and he immediately starts like kind of
flirting back and being like kind of
like yeah i'm into
this chick and maybe she digs me too and
all this other kind of stuff
so she basically kind of brings them in
the house
they get him all set up and the creepy
thing like i said this is why this was
my
favorite part of the book was because
the creepy thing is that
it always seems like there's servants in
the house because like [ __ ] gets done
like his you know his bags get carried
up to his room like all his clothes get
laid out
there's always like really nice food
laid out but he never sees
anybody and the woman who originally was
there to like lead him into the house
and like tell him a little bit about the
[ __ ]
he never sees her again either even
though he very much
hopes to because like i said he kind of
has he kind of develops like a thing for
her very quickly
the only other person that he sees in
the house is this other dude
who you're led to assume
at first is kind of like the overseer
of the library because at this point i
think the manor even though it's still
owned by the seneschal
family and he seems to think that the
the two remaining uh living seneschals
who would be very elderly are still
living in the house but he never sees
them either
although in the other wing of the house
he does see like lights and what
look like figures like walking right
over there but he never really sees them
but this one dude that he sees he just
presumes
because he gives him the name robert
wall so he's just presuming that
this is the dude that's like overseeing
the libraries like overseeing the
foundation because that's like
basically what this house is now it's
like a literary foundation
so this guy again like seems very
friendly very helpful although
when um william asks him a couple
particular questions he seems
not standoffish exactly but like he
doesn't really want to answer them or he
just kind of like changes the subject
like
yeah let's just talk about something
else like he didn't hear him or
something so he thinks that's a little
bit weird
and this guy but like i said he seems
very uh friendly
but then again like little weird things
happen like they keep giving william the
same dinner
which is like some kind of like meat
dish with mushrooms which
apparently was the same thing that
isabelle standish uh ate
like his relative like when she was
staying there and writing poems
and he always has they always give him
the same breakfast which is like kippers
and like something else that i can't
remember the pronunciation of which he
like finds really gross but they keep
giving it to him anyway
and like i said he never sees anybody in
the kitchen he never like he goes in the
kitchen and like the stove is hot but
there's no
there's nobody in there but you know he
always has
food and like really nice wine and
scotch and everything like that
so robert wall who he talks to for like
you know it's it's a night and i think
he sees him the next day but then that
guy is basically like oh okay i have to
go like do some business or something
and then he never sees that guy again
either
now as the story goes on it's almost
kind of like i this one i don't really
want to spoil
too much um although i may just a little
bit
you know just like some of my other ones
i never really know what i'm going to
say like on these i just kind of turned
the camera on and just start talking but
it starts out almost like a ghost story
you're kind of either led to believe
that either the seneschals
are dead or their kids are dead or
something like that and they're ghosts
or that the ghost of isabel standish is
haunting the place because he seems to
hear like a woman giggling he seems to
like
feel or see someone in his room
sometimes
he hears footsteps like just standard
like haunting like ghost [ __ ]
but as the story goes on you start to
question
whether this dude is just
losing his marbles because the one thing
about this book that i will say and
the reviews i've read of this were very
very mixed like some people really
really loved this book
and then i read a couple reviews of it
that were very very negative
one criticism that i will agree with is
that the [ __ ]
one what's going on in this story is not
super clear at least at first reading
like i said i've read this twice
but i didn't one i didn't realize that
this was the second time i was reading
it really
and two by the time i figured that out i
was like well i read it the first time
like such a long time ago that it didn't
really register like what was going on
so i feel like this might need a second
reading because
some of the stuff that happens i was
like reading i was like wait what
like i wasn't really sure what exactly
was going on
so that's why i kind of think that it's
ambiguous in the sense
that you don't really know
if the [ __ ] that william standish is
going through like
there's a possibility that he just could
be a completely unreliable narrator
so i'm not really sure at this point i'm
not really sure if he actually ever even
went to england like maybe this whole
[ __ ] is just like in his imagination
you know that's how far i'm going that's
like how ambiguous this story is like
you could totally read it
as him never having gone there at all or
him having gone there
and nothing was it because there is one
scene in there
and again this is spoiler alert spoiler
so if you don't want to like know
anything
you know what are you doing watching
this i don't really know but you know
if if you don't want to know anything
about the story then probably like don't
listen to it any further than this but
there is one scene
where he goes to the village
uh he goes down to the village like near
the house because s woodhouse is like
kind of out
in the sticks like out in the middle of
nowhere and then it's like you know it's
it's a little way to the village
so he goes to the village like looking
for some family graves because he's
trying to like figure out this mystery
having to do with the family
and while he's there he talks to this
really surly
vicar who basically
tells him i mean from what i'm
understanding is basically tells him
that nobody lives in that house
so i think that from a certain
point i think william is just like
imagining it i don't even know if
anybody lives in the house because like
i said
he never sees anybody except for the
first woman that comes to the door and
then he doesn't see her again
and then this the other dude robert wall
who is there for
like 24 hours like that and then he
never sees him again either
but the weird thing is that there do
seem to be other people in the house
because they're like oh well while
you're working in the library like on
isabelle's poems or whatever
um if you need anything you know like
pens or
what have you just write it down on a
piece of paper and leave it outside of
the
library door and then like he leaves the
note out there and then like a few
minutes later like the shit's there
so it's almost kind of like magical and
like i said as the story goes on
it starts to go like weirder and weirder
and weirder
until you're just getting get to a point
where it's almost like surreal and
you're not really sure
what when that line was crossed is what
i'm saying like he's he starts exploring
the house
and he finds this room with like these
big doll houses that are like exactly
replicas of the main house but are like
big enough for a kid to sit in
he finds a room that's like full of
bones he finds like all this weird kind
of [ __ ]
and is like figuring all this weird [ __ ]
about the family like maybe they're
immortal or maybe they're still alive
like even
like maybe robert wall is actually the
seneschal guy even though that guy would
be like 90 years old even but he's not
and like i said the implication too is
that if these writers
did stay at this house um which
presumably they really did because
there's photographs and stuff
that you know stuff like you know the
turn of the screw like henry james like
this
house was supposedly the um you know the
the inspiration for that for the house
and turn of the screw
so he's kind of trying to make it so
that this house or
there's some kind of like vortex or
energy around this house that
is kind of like i'm not sure if he's
like suggesting that it makes people
immortal or it makes i'm not really sure
because
isabelle standish the poet who is
william's um
you know ancestor who he's come over
here to research presumably
that she like is still at the house
but not so you know what i mean so it's
kind of like that kind of thing
and i will say too that toward the end
the end of this
is a little bit i feel like william's
descent
into madness which i think is what it is
it's very very reminiscent of the
shining and i'm not the first person to
notice that a lot of other reviewers
have also noted these similarities
between particularly the second half of
this story and
jack's kind of descent into madness and
the shining um you know the
dude in this even uses an axe and you
know does similar things kind of
tries to destroy the house and
everything so it is kind of similar in
that regard
but i will say i feel like i like this
story a lot i feel like it
might have been better as a longer work
because i felt i feel like
it was a little bit abrupt like the
stuff that happened toward the end
because like i said it was kind of like
seemed like oh it's kind of like a
regular ghost story but like a little
bit weird there was like just
like little weird creepy things
happening which i thought was really
cool
but then all of a sudden like the dude
is going around the house finding all
this weird [ __ ] and then suddenly he's
got an axe and he's running around naked
covered in blood and all of it so it
just seemed like a little bit of an
abrupt transition is all i'm saying you
know it's a very very short story
that said like and one other criticism i
could give it is it took me a little
bit to get into the story because like i
said i'm not super familiar with
you know the world of academia so
the first little bit of it were first
introduced to william and they're
talking a little bit about
the politics of the you know college
where he works and
their kind of like [ __ ] rivalry about
who's going to get the fellowship
and his you know and him like kind of
thinking about his wife's affair and
that kind of stuff
um so it took a little bit that's that
part of it's not very long but it did
kind of
take a little bit for me to get into it
and like i said he's not a super likable
character
nothing you know there's no rule that
says that they need to be and it didn't
really bother me i'm not really bothered
by
unlikable characters as long as the
story is compelling which i think this
one is
um uh to a large degree as i said i
think that
the end happens a little too quickly
like the the descent into madness is
just like
you know it seemed like it happened way
too fast
because the build up was really good and
then all of a sudden just everything
went
banana pants and i was just kind of like
okay so this is what we're doing now
all right but you know it's i guess it's
like kind of a minor criticism but i
would have liked to see this as a longer
work
because in general this is uh obviously
not the first peter straub i've read
um you know i've read houses without
doors like i said which uh you know
which is very good and has
the original version of mrs god in it
which is a little bit shorter than this
one i think
it had like a bunch of other really good
short stories in it i've also read ghost
story of course several times which
probably is my favorite book of his
i've read coco which is also very good
lost boy lost girl and like you know
several other ones and even some of his
more recent ones i've read too
and i've always like really really dug
his work
um so this one i feel like is
cool and was like a cool idea i just
feel like the end of it maybe should
have been
lengthened a little bit so and i think
that some of the
even though i like ambiguity and horror
stories generally
i think there are some things in this
that could have been clarified a little
bit better because
just from one reading and i'm not a
dummy like you know what it's
you know i read i like ambiguous things
i like things like that
but when i was reading this i found
myself a lot of times being like wait
what is going on and then like having to
go back like a few paragraphs and be
like did i miss something like what
like who is like what is going on right
now and like what
what does that mean is like she so she
lives there she didn't die i was like i
don't know
so it just seemed like a little like the
end of it was a little bit muddled
is all i'm gonna say but other than that
i actually really did enjoy this this
was another one and like i said
most of these i read in one sitting two
sittings at most
usually one of the reasons that i wanted
to do this one for this particular
show was because i knew that this was
the book that i was going to be reading
over thanksgiving
week so i said well it's good because
it's really short and i won't feel like
you know because it's the holidays in
case like other stuff comes up
um i'll still get a book finished and
still get a book review out without
having to worry about like finishing
this big long thing and having to rush
through it
so this was a very very quick read like
i said not my favorite
peter straub but uh a really decent
story like kind of
ambiguous ghoster if you like the
shining certainly give it a whirl
because it's kind of
similarly themed i guess you know
academic kind of goes to this remote
place and
you don't really know if it's if it's
ghosts or if it's craziness or if it's
combination of both things
um so i like that kind of uh i like that
kind of story so i liked this a lot like
i said took me a little bit to get into
at the beginning and the end is a little
bit
oh all right that's this is happening
but you know
other than that it's a perfectly fine
perfectly
entertaining horror story if you like
that kind of thing
so check it out uh it's called mrs god
and uh
it originally came out in 1990 but this
trade
this trade uh hardback i believe only
came out a few years ago
i think there's also a limited edition
as i mentioned earlier
so if you're into peter straub and
haven't read it then check it out and i
will see you on the next one
bye